ihr Wahrheit und nicht als sie Wahrheit das
haben wir uns vorgenommen ja genau so heißt
ja auch das Programm genau was wenn wir so durch
auf Tour sind bzw sind wir gar nicht mehr waren ne
damals erinnern wir uns also Tour gefahren sind
was haben wir da gemacht wir haben übernachtet
und so guten Hotels mit Frühstück hieß es
immer ne absolut ja da saßen wir in diesem
Frühstücksbuffet ich habe immer in der regionalen
Zeitung die Todesanzeigen und die Kontaktanzeigen
gelesen gemacht na ich scrolle immer so durch
die Nachrichten das ist so mein Ding ne und
dann lese ich immer so die Mittelschicht spricht
zusammen dann scroll ich ein bisschen weiter und
dann lese ich der Wirtschaft geht so gut wie nie
dann voll Beschäftigung ist wohl noch weiter das
System was am Ende des kollabiert und die
Leute wollen es abschaffen dann scroll ich
noch ein bisschen weiter das Gesundheitssystem
ist das beste der Welt das sind für mich nichts
messages es ist Russisch gemischte Wahrheit
ah weißt du ich verstehe es nicht verstehst du
gerade ach so
tut mir leid ist okay
[Applaus]
ist ja viel grundsätzlicher um welche
Realität geht überhaupt ne mit welcher
Matrix beschäftigen wir uns weil wenn du mir
sagst das System kollabiert gleich weil alles
auf Pump ist und weil alle zwei bis drei
Jobs brauchen um ihre Miete zu zahlen dann
fahre ich mich schau dir das noch mal an ne
ist es Ausverkauf Franz ne ja toll und wenn
jetzt diese Virus nicht weg werden hier
800 Leute und würden sich einen Vortrag
über geometrisches Essen anhören weißt du wie
erklärst du denn das ja in diesem Arm Land haben
wie viel hat die Karte hier gekostet wie viel 15
€ Weg ne so weißt du sag mal ganz ehrlich stimmt
nicht aus das wird sein jetzt wird aus ne also
das was ich verstehe es nicht wie das System
weißt du im letzten Jahr da wurden 300 Millionen
Pkws zugelassen ne davon 1 Million SUVs wie geht
das macht die Rubbellose macht die Gangster Rap
wie geht das wie macht ihr das ne oder ich war
hier in Hannover war ich auf der Caravan
Messe warum um mir ein Bild zu machen ach
so um faktisch richtig zu berichten ne und die
neuesten Modelle die sind ja die sind ja hier
die sind länger als ein Reisebus ne damit der
Porsche Carrera da unten Platz hat ne für die
Stadtrundfahrt ne diese Branche hat zweistellige
zufallsraten hier in banglade der Schweiz sind ne
und ich konnte gar nicht kaufen der Wagen war
vorgestellt ne so das tut mir aber sehr alter
vielleicht ist es so ist es die Realität oder
oder wird mir alles vorgespielt ihr seid alle
Schauspieler oder ist eine einzige Truman Show
nur für mich ne und ich bin Erich Honecker auf
seiner protokollstrecke von Wand sitzen in der
Mitte ne die einzige Straße die noch funktioniert
und die Obdachlosen werden von mir weggekehrt
wenn ich komme und frisch gewaschene Menschen
treten super sanierten Häusern raus und wegen
mir zu hallo hallo alles gut hier super System
super mach weiter so und das
sagt ich liebe euch alle ist das
oder nee auch nicht vielleicht ist ja so ich
spiele ja auch noch was vor ich lüge euch ja
an vor allem auf Instagram in diesem lügenportal
ne vor zwei Tagen saß noch so aus ne da saß ich
zu Hause fertig mit der Welt ne ich habe ein
halbes Jahr nichts gemacht ich Gammel rum in
meiner Wohnung ich kann nicht entfernen sie
haben alles vergessen ne auf Instagram ja ich
bin gerade in Paris geiles Ding hier kommt alle
vorbei ich bin gerade in New York nee ich mache
hier ein geil hier ich bin auf Safari hier ich
mache hier eine Kreuzfahrt ich mache hier ich
bin im Basislager muss am gesellschaftlichen Leben
teilnehmen ich bin auf der Erde Rundung nee die
Wahrheit ist das nee jetzt Photoshop das ist die
Wahrheit ich weiß doch ich weiß nicht läuft haben
ich weiß ihr habt euch alle diesen
Abend von Munde abgespart um einmal
was Schönes zu erleben hier
im September ist es richtig
ja Schlusslicht aus Zitat die Realität
ist ein Mischbrot wer hat gesagt weiß
ich nicht aber es ist ähm ich habe das
gelesen eine alleinerziehende Mutter aus
Berlin Marzahn ich kann sie ändern es war
so er hat ihrem Sohn zu Weihnachten ein
Handyvertrag geschenkt und hat dafür für
die Krebs auf die Krebsvorsorge verzichtet
ne nächstes Jahr halten muss reichen ne man
muss Abstriche machen das wollte ich sagen